6-6 left-hander daniel lynch for the
third time this year
daniel lynch man is he exciting to watch
you know why because he can pitch and it
will be romy gonzalez in his first major
league start playing leadoff man he's
faced lynch in the minor leagues
daniel's on his game the first batter he
should be and there he goes he comes
right back with the slider now 28 of his
41 strikeouts this year have been on
this pit how's the big league taste now
that's really tough here is robert
playing center field
oh luis robert charges this ball up left
center field no chance it is a
splashdown he did not miss that ball
how strong is that dude he hits a
fastball about 435 feet right here and
it is a no doubter to deep deep left
center it's one nothing white sox in the
first his seventh of the season so with
two down it brings up yasmani grandahl
the switch hitter batting right-handed
here's the pitch there's a drive to
center well hit and deep and it will go
a home run
two-run homer grand all
three-nothing in the first
talk about putting a charge in a 3-2
fastball we just witnessed it what a
difference a day makes and they will
face a rejuvenated reynaldo lopez we
talked about it on the pre-game reynaldo
has come in with a different attitude
ever since he got sent down and he came
back up he also was working in the pen
up the middle lopez has the boomerang
and there is out number one now faces
nikki lopez the shortstop
2-2 struck him out
ronaldo lopez you see his reaction it
was almost like he knew it was going to
be a strikeout his confidence is through
the roof
cesar hernandez leads off three-nothing
white sox inning number two mentioned
his 21
home runs a career high and now he takes
a slider from
lynch and strike three called the number
nine hitter the shortstop danny mendick
[Applause]
merrifield shovels it two santana nice
stretch got him width makes everything
look easy but they're not
very soft hands he's able to just shovel
it over there no problem he's a board
and the batter is abreu the 3-2
that ball is ripped he got his hands
around on a high fastball
and stroked it to left
ball four throw to third gets into left
field robert's going to get up and score
and abreu's into third so it was a walk
and gallagher threw it
into left field gallagher whips it well
over third base jimenez walks to first
and it's four nothing yeah they're going
to have a chat
with lynch they think something could be
wrong with it you know what they're
looking at is his hand and it looks like
a little little blister or something
exactly and the red hot granddaugh at
the plate he's already hit a two-run
homer tonight the 0-1 is hammered into
center that's a base hit a brayuse
scores grand doll's got three rbis
tonight
it is five to nothing and he keeps on
squaring up baseballs so runners at the
corners again this time with one away
and an rbi chance for leori garcia
garcia aligned drive to left ben and
tendy fading on it and this will be an
rbi for laori garcia on a sacrifice fly
and it's six nothing socks here in the
third and rivera begins the bottom of
the third inning with a double cam
gallagher's at the plate
gallagher with a base hit here comes
rivera
the throw to the plate by vaughan off
line the royals on the scoreboard
perez with a runner at first two down
perez to dead centerfield robert back
and see you later alex gordon
because salvador perez is now fourth all
time in royals history with home runs
with
191. that's what the folks came to see
salvador perez unloaded on that fastball
with no doubter 39th on the season it is
a 6-3 game all i know is at this point
runners on the corners in a huge run for
abreu to drive in
another 2-2
swinging a drive to center well hit
and it is over taylor's head right at
the wall mendix scores
robert to third jose's got a double his
500th career extra base hit
it's 7-3 and the bases are loaded with
one down for the sox here in the fourth
jazz wanted to tee off and he skies it
to center field it's robert at third and
taylor makes the catch robert tags he's
on his way home and the sox get another
run here it's eight to three and that
feels kind of important just for a
little extra separation
chance for his first major league rbi
on the ground third base side
and there it is the first rbi for romy
gonzalez garcia scores and it's 9-3 and
you might want to save that baseball
number five and the royals have runners
at the corners with two down for
salvador perez
delivers and a swing and a high fly ball
deep left center field way back and that
ball is gone
another home run for salvador perez his
40th a three-run shot and the royals
again pull within three it's nine to six
carlos
has not hit a home run in well over a
month
santana with a blast
and the drought is over
he had gotten 131 at bats since his last
home run but he teed off on michael
kopeck it is 9-7
del salvador perez will bat as the tying
run in the seventh inning seventh inning
this is the at-bat of the ball game two
and two
there it is in town he goes that's nasty
strike a guy out like that after the day
he's had wow he wasn't close gordo no
latter's spawn with runners at first and
third a stretch and a pitch there's a
base hitting to right
abraham will score grand all stops at
second it's 10-7
that's a huge add-on run
see what liam's been doing we all know
him closer for the white sox right i
mean he's going gonna throw a fastball
he's gonna come right at guys
one two
oh slider tight down at the bottom of
the zone two down
sox could end up with a ten and a half
game lead cleveland lost earlier there's
a line shot caught
garcia at third down to a knee
that ball caught him more than he caught
it
but the white sox beat the royals
tonight and the final score from
kauffman stadium white sox 10
royals seven